شهدت العاصمه القطريه التوقيع على اعلان
في ختام المباحثات بين الرئيس الفلسطيني
محمود عباس وخالد مشعل رئيس المكتب
السياسي لحركه حماس وقد نص الاعلان على ان
يتولى عباس رئاسه حكومه انتقاليه توافقيه
تشرف على اجراء
انتخابات
[موسيقى]
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لكي نناقشه في عنوانين
رئيسين ما هي الدلالات التي يحملها
التوافق الجديد وما هي ضمانات ان تبصر
مقرراته
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
النور توقيع اخر اعلان اخر للمصالحه
الفلسطينيه الفلسطينيه بعنوانها
العارضين فتح وحماس التوقيع الذي تم
برعايه الشيخ حمد بن خليفه الثاني امير
دوله قطر ينص للمره الاولى على ان يتولى
رئيس السلطه الفلسطينيه محمود عباس رئاسه
حكومه انتقاليه توافقيه تشرف على اجراء
الانتخابات وعلى اعاده م غزه والاهم ان
يطوي صفحه
الخلافات اتفاق الدوحه هو النقطه الاولى
لمرحله ما بعد صراع فتح وحماس الطويل
والذي ظهرت بوادره بعد قليل من فوز حماس
في الانتخابات التشريعيه عام 2006
وتشكيلها حكومه لم تنل رضا غربيين كثيرين
وبينهم امريكا التي ما فتئت تنظر لحماس
كعقبة كانت وجهات نظر فتح وحماس او السلطه
الفلسطينيه والحكومه الجديده على طرفي
نقيض وتطورت خلافاتهما وصراعاته حتى
انفردت حماس عام 2007 بالسيطره على كل
قطاع غزه وما تبع ذلك من اقاله عباس
لحكومه هانيه تعقد الخلاف حتى العدوان
الاسرائيلي على غزه في ديسمبر عام 2008 لم
يحقق الوحده او التنسيق بين فتح وحماس رغم
ان العدوان دمر ارضا فلسطينيه قتل مئات
الفلسطينيين وشرد الالاف ولا تزال اثاره
ماثله حتى الان ويعتقد كثيرون ان التدخل
الدولي وخاصه الغربي والذي يتعامل مع
القضيه الفلسطينيه واطرافها وفق
استراتيجياته اسهم كثيرا في اذكاء نيران
الفتنه بحيث لم تجدي تدخلات كثير من
المصلحين
فتيله شهدت السنوات الماضيه عددا من
مشروعات المصالحه جمعت فتح وحماس ولكن
الفشل استمر وكان الخلاف اكبر من جهود
الحل حتى بلغ الجميع محطه اتفاق القاهره
العام الماضي والذي انطلقت بموجبه تطبيقات
الدوحه
الحاليه ينفذ الطرفان الان اتفاق الدوحه
والتزم ببنوده في ظل الدعم العربي الذي
يحظى به الاتفاق والمنطلق من القناعه التي
جرى التعبير عنها هنا بان الوحده
الفلسطينيه مصير يدعمه العرب وان المصالحه
لم تعد مصلحه فلسطينيه بقدر ما هي مصلحه
عربيه ولكن يبقى من المبكر التكهن بشكل
السنه الفلسطينيه القادمه رغم ما اعلنه
الطرفان عن جديته في تنفيذ كل مجالات
الاتفاق والمحك هو انجاح مهمه الاعداد
للانتخابات الرئاسيه والتشريعيه واعاده
تشكيل المجلس الوطني وهي مهمه ليست بالسهل
وفي الذهن تجارب كثيره بينها دور الولايات
المتحده تحديدا التي لم تعترف يوما بحماس
كشريك الهم او سلام الشرق الاوسط الذي
ترعاه ومناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من غزه
مخيمر ابو سعده استاذ العلوم السياسيه في
جامعه الازهر ومن رام الله عبد الستار
قاسم استاذ الفكر السياسي في جامعه النجاح
سيد مخيمر ما دلالات هذا الاعلان من
الدوحه
اليوم بصراحه انا بعتقد بانه يعني ان يخرج
هذا الاجتماع برعايه قطريه له دلالات مهمه
جدا خاصه وان قطر باتت تلعب دورا اساسيا
في منطقه الشرق الاوسط وخاصه ان قطر يعني
يمكن القول بانها تقف على مسافه واحده من
من طرفي الصراع فتح وحماس وحتى كانت تتهم
قطر بانها في السابق
كانت تدعم او تعمل لصالح حماس اكثر مما
تعمل لصالح فتح على ايه حال بعتقد باعتبار
ان قطر هي وسيط الان بين حركه حماس من
ناحيه والاردن من ناحيه ثانيه وا قطر تلعب
دور محوري في ثورات الربيع العربي بعتقد
بانه هذا اصبح يؤهلها الان لان تكون وسيط
بين فتح وحماس وبالتاكيد هناك دعم دولي من
المجتمع الدولي لهذه الوساطه القطريه
والتي نتج عنها اتفاق الدوحه اليوم الذي
يؤسس لمرحله جديده في المصالحه الفلسطينيه
هل تعتقد بان الربيع العربي ساهم ايضا
و تصدرت قطر هذا المشهد الدبلوماسي في
العالم العربي في ظل انقفال قوى اخرى هل
ترى بان هذا الدور الحالي القطري سببه
انكفاء قوى اخرى مثلا كان هنالك اتفاق
اتفاق القاهره لم يستكمل له النجاح لانه
كان في ض ظل النظام القديم الان هنالك
نظام جديد ولكنه مشغول ب نتائج ما بعد
الثوره ما
رايك هو بصراحه المنطقه العربيه اصبحت في
وضع سياسي مختلف كليا عما كان عليه الوضع
قبل عام الربيع العربي والثورات التي حدثت
في تونس ومصر وليبيا وسوريا وغيرها من
الدول العربيه انتجت واقعا عربيا جديدا لم
يعد ما كانت المنطقه في السابق ان المنطقه
يتنازعها تياران تيار الاعتدال الذي كانت
تتزعم مصر والسعوديه والاردن وتيار
الممانعه والمقاومه الذي تزعمت سوريا
وايران وحماس وحزب الله هذه القواعد الى
حد ما انتهت مع الثورات العربيه والتغيرات
التي شهدتها المنط المنطقه ونجاح حركات
الاسلام السياسي بالانتخابات في الكثير من
الدول العربيه ولهذا انا بعتقد انه بصراحه
ثورات الربيع العربي وبالتحديد ما حدث في
سوريا هو كان دافع اساسي باتجاه حركه حماس
ان تقبل بال المصالحه الفلسطينيه وان تقبل
باعاده صياغه النظام السياسي الفلسطيني
على قاعده الشراكه السياسيه بصراحه في في
السابق كانت تتهم مصر بانها
منحازه لطرف على حساب الاخر وبانها لم تكن
على مسافه واحده من طرفي الصراع ولذلك انا
بتصور ان الواقع السياسي الجديد في
المنطقه العربيه ساعد حركه حماس على الاقل
بان تذهب باتجاه المصالحه الفلسطينيه خاصه
بعد ان خسرت حماس هذا ال ولكن ساعدت فتح
ايضا سي سيد مخيمر ساعدت فتح ايضا بالنظر
الى ان او او طرت ايضا فتح من جانبها الى
ان ايضا ام تستعد اكثر للمصالحه بالنظر
الى ان مصر في النظام القديم كانت متهمه
بانها منحازه
لفتح انا بصراحه لا انكر ذلك ان ان قطر
ساعدت الطرفين ولكن انا عندما انظر الى
الاتفاق الذي وقع في الرابع من من مايو من
عام 2011 واتفاق اليوم انا بصراحه اعتقد
بان حماس
قدمت يعني قدمت تساهلا او او يعني كان
هناك تساهل ومرونه سياسيه من جانب حماس في
اكثر من قضيه اولا اليوم هي وافقت على ان
يتولى الرئيس محمود عباس رئاسه حكومه
التوافق الوطني الفلسطيني ثانيا حماس وعلى
لسان السيد خالد مشعل قبلت ب اعتماد او
تبني المقاومه الشعبيه السلميه وحماس كمان
اكثر من ذلك توافق على المفاوضات مع
اسرائيل على اساس الثوابت والحقوق الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه ولذلك انا بعتقد بانه كان هناك
مرونه سياسيه من جانب حماس قدمتها خلال
العام الاخير مما مهد ل لهذه الاتفاقات
التي رايناها في
مام حدث اليوم سيد قاسم ضيفي من رام الله
اذا هل ترى بان حماس سمحت بمرونتها هذه
كما يراها السيد مخيمر بالوصول الى هذا
الاعلان والمصالحه
اليوم والله هو مجمل ظروف هي ليست فقط
مرونه حماس علما ان حماس يعني او بصوره
عامه هي لا تتبنى خطا سياسيا جامدا وانما
لديها الاستعداد للاخذ والعطاء مع مختلف
الفصائل الفلسطينيه وايضا مع مختلف الدول
في المحيط فالكل يبدي مرونه لكن في
الاساس المرونه تاتي من ان كلا ال
الفصيلين لا يريدان اعطاء انطباع للشعب
الفلسطيني انهما لا يريدان المصالحه فكل
واحد
يتسابق مع الاخر نحو المصالحه ويشير في
وسائل اعلامه المختلفه للشعب الفلسطيني
بانه لا يمانع وهو الذي يدفع باتجاه
المصالحه لان المصالحه تضر في الشعب
الفلسطيني فهذه جدليه سمعناها وما زلنا
نسمعها حتى الان على مدى السنوات منذ عام
2005 حتى قبل ال 2006 كان يقال هذا الكلام
مجمل الظروف طبعا في هناك ارباح وخسائر ل
لكل واحد على المستوى الاقليمي وبالتالي
يتجهان نحو هذه المرونه
لكن هل هذه المرونه ستؤدي في النهايه الى
مصالحه حقيقيه او الى وحده فلسطينيه هذا
ما سننظر فيه حقيقه لانه نحن جربنا مرارا
وتكرارا مثل هذه الاتفاقيات والاعلانات
هناك الان عنصر اضافي جديد وهو عنصر قطر
لم يكن موجود بشكل واضح وكبير وهذا العنصر
يعطينا انطباع الانطباع الاول اللي هو
يعني احتمال قبول المجموعه الغربيه بهذا
الاتفاق المجموعه الغربيه التي تسمي نفسها
المجتمع الدولي والاحتمال الاخر انه تقوم
قطر بسد الثغره الماليه التي يمكن ان تطرا
عن اتفاق حقيقي ما بين الفصيلين اذا حصل
اتفاق حقيقي وطبعا ما اعنيه بالحقيقي هو
التطبيق العملي على الارض لانه سيكون في
هناك نوع من النقص المالي من الذي سيسدد
وقطر ربما لا تستطيع ان تسدده دون ان يكون
هناك قبول من المجموعه الغربيه وما شابه
ذلك وبالتالي هذا احتمال وارد بسبب دخول
قدر لكن دعينا ننتظر وانا الا نصل الى
النتائج بهذه السهوله لكن ابو مازن نفسه
اكد باننا لم نوقع هذا الاتفاق الا
لتطبيقه ابو مازن قال هذا الكلام
مرارا انا لا استطيع ان اخذ كلامه الان
بجد لانه جرب رارا ع انت تشكك سيد سيد
قاسم تشكك وتقول دعونا نرى يعني وكانك
تلمح الى انه قد يكون مثل باقي الاتفاقات
وان يفشل طيب اذا كان نتنياهو نفسه غاضبا
من هذا يعني اغضب الحكومه الاسرائيليه
اغضبت الحكومه الاسرائيليه هذه المصالحه
بالتالي لها نتائج على الارض وعاده
الافعال تبدا بنيات نيات تؤدي الى الى
اقوال اقوال تؤدي الى افعال اليست هذه
خطوه اولى تؤدي الى تطبيق فعليا على على
الارض نحن نامل ذلك نامل ذلك لكن اذا كنت
لا اشكك انا بكون فلسطيني ابله لانه هذه
تكررت ومن عام 2005 حتى الان وقعت
اتفاقيات عديده بين الطرفين ولم تطبق الان
ما هو موقف نتنياهو هذا لايعنيني انا
يعنيني موقف الشعب الفلسطيني وهل هذه
الاتفاقيات ستقود الى وحده فلسطينيه
حقيقيه ام لا الشعب
الفلسطيني بحسب بحسب يعني بحسب بالجو
العام ان كان في غزه او في رام الله في
الضفه الغربيه هنالك يعني تعطش من الشارع
الفلسطيني الى المصالحه والوحده الوطنيه
لانها ستعود على الجميع بالفائده اذا
بالتالي الشعب الفلسطيني لماذا لا يكون
مرحبا بهكذا خطوه لا الشعب الفلسطيني
يتمنى ويريد الوحده وهو يدفع
باتجاهها لكن الشعب الفلسطيني ايضا حذر
لانه نعم يعني اعلن مرارا و وتكرارا
الاتفاق لكنه لم يحصل وبالتالي الشعب
الفلسطيني ليس غبيا هو ذكي وبالتالي يجب
ان يصر الشعب الفلسطيني على اتفاق يطبق
على الارض ونحن نريد ان نرى اشياء على
الارض طيب سي يعني نريد ان نرى خطوات
اعتبارا من غد على الارض مثل مثلا الافراج
عن المعتقلين
السياسيين او مثلا ال اعاده الموظفين
المين الى
وف عن عن خروجهم على اي حال سيد قاسم
سنتحدث اكثر عن هذا الحذر وكيف يمكن ان
يحصن الاتفاق الجديد في وجه التحديات التي
تواجهه بالفعل سنناقش ذلك بعد فاصل قصير
فانتظرونا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اهلا بكم من جديد في حلقتنا التي تتناول
اعلان الدوحه للتوافق الفلسطيني على حكومه
انتقاليه برئاسه محمود عباس سيد مخيمر
ضيفي من غزه طرح السيد قاسم هواجس وقال ان
هنالك حذر كبير يعني الكل يريد هذه
المصالحه ولكن يريد تطبيقات على ارض
الواقع كيف ترى انت من وجهه نظرك هذه
الهواجس وهل مبرر هذا
الحذر
بصراحه الحذر الذي تحدث عنه الدكتور عبد
الستار قاسم هو في محله لو عدنا الى
الوراء فهو كما تحدث هناك مجموعه من
الاتفاقيات التي حصلت بخصوص المصالحه
الفلسطينيه ولم تنفذ لا اريد ان اذكر
المشاهدين بانه كان هناك اتفاق مكه الذي
وقع في فبراير من عام 2007 ولم يصمد هذا
الاتفاق اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر والذي انتهى
باقتتال فلسطيني ادى الى سيطره حماس على
قطاع ز فعلا ثانيا نعم فعلا هذا الاتفاق
مكا وصولا الى اتفاق القاهره وكلها يعني
لم يكن النجاح حليفها طيب هذا هذا صحيح
ولكن انت قلت في اجابتك الاولى بان ظروف
تغيرت في المنطقه بسبب الثورات وبسبب
الربيع العربي وغياب انظمه عن الساحه كانت
يعني هذه الانظمه تدع تدعم طرف على حساب
طرف اخر عندما غابت عن المشهد هذه
الانظمه اذا تغيرت المعادله وربما هذا
يسمح بنجاح هذا اتفاق هذه
المره صحيح انا لازلت كما قلت ولكن انا
كنت اتحدث عن حاله الاحباط التي تسود في
الشارع الفلسطيني والحذر الذي يسود في
الشارع الفلسطيني نتيجه الاخفاقات على
مدار الخمس سنوات الماضيه ولكن حتى لا
افرط في التفاؤل انا بصراحه حتى هذه
اللحظه يعني الظروف تغيرت في المنطقه
والتيارات الاعتدال والممانعه لم تعد
موجوده كما كانت في السابق ولكن انا اعتقد
انه هناك مشكله الان تكمن في حركتي فتح
وحماس من موضوع المصالحه الفلسطينيه انا
بصراحه من خلال اطلاعي على الاوضاع هنا في
غزه اعتقد ان حركه حماس بحاجه الى حصول
على اجماع على على المرو على يعني التقدم
في ملف المصالحه الفلسطينيه لا اخفي عليك
ولا اقول سرا بان هناك خلافات في داخل
حركه حماس حول موضوع المصالحه وحل وحول
امكانيه تطبيق ما اتفق عليه وهذا لاحظناه
من خلال تصريحات اكثر من مره التي صدرت عن
الدكتور محمود الزهار وهو قيادي بارز في
حركه حماس والذي شكك في اكثر من مره من
امكانيه المصالحه وهو بصراحه يعتقد بانه
اي مصالحه يجب ان ترتكز على اساس برنامج
المقاومه وعلى اساس وقف التنسيق الامني مع
اسرائيل وعلى اساس اعاده صياغه الاجهزه
الامنيه الفلسطينيه على عقيده امنيه جديده
دحم الوطن والمواطن بصراحه نحن بحاجه الى
شوط كبير حتى نصل الى هذه التفاهمات في كل
هذه القضايا التي طرحتها
ولذلك الظروف الاقليميه تغيرت ولكن
الاوضاع الفلسطينيه للاسف لم تتغير تغير
القضايا الجوهريه تقصد سيد قاسم الذين
يشككون في نجاعه او في نجاح هذا هذه
المصالحه ما
بديلهم طبعا ال الاساس انه يجب معالجه
الاسباب التي ادت الى الاقتتال والصراع
الداخلي الفلسطيني هذه الاتفاقيات جميعها
منذ اتفاق القاهره عام 2005 اللي هو قبل
عمليه الانقسام حتى الان لم تعالج الاسباب
وهذه كانت واضحه الاسباب منذ عام 1993 مع
اتفاقيه اوسلو وانا واحد من الناس الذين
قالوا في عام 1993 ان الدم الفلسطيني
سينزف بسبب هذه
الاتفاقيات لانه واضح انها ستحدث شرخا
كبيرا جدا الان اذا اردنا ان نعالج
الانقسام يجب ان نعالج الاسباب ولا نعالج
المظاهر هذه مساله طبيه يعني وبسيطه ولا
تحتاج الى عبقريه حتى الان هذه الاتفاقيات
تعالج بعض المظاهر تحاول ان توصل للشعب
الفلسطيني رساله بان ه الاخوه يتحابون
ويتعرق ويتبادلون القبل لكن هذا لا يكفي
وانما بحاجه الى خطوات ح حتى سي بعدين في
اشياء في قضايا اساسيه هنالك خلاف ربما
فكري ايديولوجي يعود كما تقول الى زمن
اوسلو ولكن جربوا الخلاف ولم يعد عليهم
بالنفع للجانبين ولم يعد بالنفع للاهم
الشعب الفلسطيني لم يعد بالنفع على الشعب
الفلسطيني نفسه الم يحن الاوان
لايجاد ارضيه مشتركه حل وسط يجمع قد لا
يعني قد لا يكون بالضروره ان يوافقوا ان
ان ان يتبنوا نفس الراي ولكن على الاقل ان
يعملوا ما هو حل وسط لافاده الشعب
الفلسطيني لانه في خلال هذه السنوات لم
يستفد احد نعم
نعم اخت غاده المساله ليست ايديولوجيه
المساله في المقاربات يعني حماس هي حركه
مقاومه الاخوان المسلمين لهم ايديولوجيا
وعقيده معينه نعم لكن كماس هي لها لها
مقاربه معينه وفتح لها مقاربه اخرى مختلفه
بل متناقضه يعني المقاربات متناقضه
وبالتالي المساله فنيه اكثر منها
ايديولوجيه ف اذا اردنا ان نحصل على حل ط
عظيم اذا كانت فنيه اذا ربما حتى اسهل من
الايديولوجيه الان هذا هذا وصلنا الى هنا
الى اعلان الدوحه اتفاق مصالحه في الدوحه
سيد قاسم ما هي النصيحه التي يمكن ان
يسديها مطلع على هذه الامور كي يصمد هذا
الاتفاق و يستفيد منه الشعب الفلسطيني ان
كان في غزه او في الضفه
الغربيه نعم هي المساله زي ما تفضلت هي
سهله لكن المشكله ان الفصائل تعقدها في
هناك تعقيدات فصائل وكما يبدو انه العقليه
القبليه هي تتفوق على عقليه الوحده
الوطنيه هنا المشكله في المقاربه فطرحت
الكثير من الافكار في الساحه الفلسطينيه
وانا اعطيك يعني المشكله الان الفصائل كيف
اتفقوا على او اتفق الفصان على السيد ابو
مازن السيد ابو مازن يعني الاتفاق عليه
كرئيس وزراء يعبر عن هذا المازق المرعب
الذي يعيشه الشعب الفلسطيني وتعيشه
القيادات يعني ابو مازن الان بده يصير
رئيس وزراء هو رئيس السلطه هو القائد
الاعلى للقوات المسلحه هو رئيس حركه فتح
هو رئيس منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه تخيلي
انه كل هذه المناصب الصعبه والشاقه التي
تتطلب الكثير من الجهود تنحصر بشخص واحد
هذا دليل انه في مازق حقيقي انه نحن
مش وصل الراحل ابو عمار كان كان يتولى عده
مناصب وكان رمزا بالنسبه للشعب الفلسطيني
ما يعني ما ما ما الخطا في ان يتولى ابو
مازن كل هذه المناصب اذا كان متفق
عليه سيد
قاسم نعم فانا اقول يجب ان توزع
المسؤوليات لا يجوز مثل هذا العمل فكان
بالامكان مثلا ان نوكل الامر لفصيل صغيرين
على الساحه الفلسطينيه لاختيار مستقلين
ولاختيار رئيس وزراء مستقل لا علاقه له
بالسياسه لكنه قادر على على اداره الشؤون
المدنيه واليوميه للشعب الفلسطيني هل هذا
صعب هذا ليس صعبا فلماذا كل هذه السنوات
وكل هذا الاستنزاف للجهود والوقت
والاستنزاف للعواطف وخلق كراهيه وبغضاء
داخل الشعب الفلسطيني في هناك مشكله
حقيقيه خلقت بين ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني
عبر هذه سنوات كيف نردم صار في ثارات صار
في حقوق انتهكت فالفصل المفروض انه يكونوا
اوعى واكثر تحملا للمسؤوليه مما نراه الان
اليست يوم اليست يوم خطوه اولى لابداء هذا
الوعي عبر هذه المصالحه في الدوحه غادا
نحن نامل ذلك وكل الشعب الفلسطيني في
الداخل والخارج يامل ذلك ونرجو الله ان
يتم الاتفاق او ان يتم تطبيقه وان نرى
خطوات عمليه على الارض كل الشعب الفلس
فلسطيني يتفق مع هذا لكن لا نستطيع ان
نسلم تفاؤلنا تسليما لما حصل وانما نبقى
حذرين تحت الاختبار وصلت فكرتك سيد مخامر
اختم معك من غزه ضيفي من غزه سيد مخيمر
اذا السيد قاسم شرح لنا التاثير السيء لل
القبليه على حساب الوطنيه الفلسطين
القبليه عند الفصائل قد تؤثر سلبا على هذا
الاتفاق انا اريد منك ايضا شرحا لتاثير
الموقف الاسرائيلي والامريكي من وراءه على
هذا الاتفاق نجاحه او
فشله ولا احد ينكر ان اسرائيل لاعب اساسي
في الساحه الفلسطينيه وكذلك المجتمع
الغربي بقياده الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ولكن انا اعتقد انه برعايه قطر لهذا
الاتفاق بالتاكيد هناك ضمانات دوليه من
قبل الرباعيه الدوليه وفي مقدمتها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه للتعامل مع اي
حكومه يتم تشكيلها برئاسه الدك الرئيس
محمود عباس ولكن اسرائيل التي دائما تحاول
ان تضع اللوم على الطرف الفلسطيني فهي على
نساء نتنياهو اليوم هو قال بان على الرئيس
عباس ان يختار بين السلام او الشراك مع
حماس هذه فقط محاولات من قبل نتنياهو لوضع
اللوم دائما على الفلسطينيين ايه بعتقد
انه لا بد من ضغط دولي على اسرائيل كي
تقبل اسرائيل بالحكومه الجديده وكي تقبل
باجراء انتخابات رئاسيه وتشريع في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه بما فيها القدس المحتله وكذلك
تسهيل مهمه الحكومه القادمه اذا قررت
اسرائيل بزعامه نتنياهو واليمين المتطرف
افشال هذه الحكومه سيكون سهلا عليها
مقاطعتها وعزلها ووضع العراقيل وال دولي
عليها وصلت فكرتك شكرا جزيلا لك من غزه
خمر ابو سعده استاذ لعلوم السياسيه في
جامعه الازهر وايضا اشكر من رام الله عبد
قاسم استاذ الفكر السياسي في جامعه النجاح
واشكركم مشاهدينا على المتابعه بهذا تنتهي
حلقه من حلقه برنامج ما وراء الخبر لهذا
اليوم نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه جديده في
ما وراء خبر جديد غدا باذن الله ترقبونا
دائما والى اللقاء باذن
[موسيقى]
الله
ه